all right let's answer some questions
the first one comes via twitter from
fifth or kid is philadelphia looking at
a quarterback in the first round now
there was a report to that effect that
the eagles would at least consider a
quarterback with the sixth overall pick
to go along with jalen hurts i would
prefer
a veteran since hertz is so young in the
nfl only his second season there's the
list of the top quarterback prospects
heading into the draft trevor lawrence
is the clear-cut number one most people
think zach wilson will go second who
knows where justin fields lands shireen
but you know we kind of talked about
this a little bit earlier veteran versus
rookie i still would rather have a
veteran paired with jalen hurts
yeah you know unless you're in love with
say
justin fields or trey lance or mac jones
if you fall in love with one of them
then i would say go ahead and do it you
know you figure out who the starting
quarterback is which one of those guys
is the franchise guy but if you're not
completely and totally sold on one of
those guys and not in love with them i'd
agree with you you go get nick foles or
whoever it might be to come in and kind
of groom jalen hurts if you truly
believe that jalen hurts is your guy and
i don't know that you saw enough of him
last year mike to figure that out i do
know that philadelphia needs to upgrade
its its roster especially on offense i
just didn't think they had enough
weapons for carson wentz the offensive
line we talked about those 14
combinations that led to 50 sacks last
year so they need to upgrade some things
on offense so if you think jalen hurts
is your guy you can get a really good
offensive player there to help out jalen
hurts
yeah i agree with you and again the
eagles view backup quarterback as a top
15 position on the entire roster so they
will make it a priority to find someone
else
posimus prime with carson wentz gone are
the eagles going to be shedding veteran
contracts in an attempt at a full
rebuild is 91 fletcher cox back look i
think that they'll look at every
position and every team is going to be
more inclined than ever before to
squeeze a guy to take less or cut him
off the roster and go out bargain
shopping for veterans there are plenty
of areas where they can upgrade i mean
al shawn jeffrey just kind of been
hanging around the roster for the past
few years i'm sure desean jackson is
going to
be gone or likely to be gone i don't
want to guarantee it's going to happen
because you never do know what a team's
going to do but there are plenty of guys
that you look at and say what are they
really doing for this team and what
could they be doing with that cap space
instead so it's not
i used this term yesterday with the
steelers it's not rebuilt it's not
reload it's more like regroup and it
definitely feels like that's what the
eagles are doing
yeah no question about it mike can you
look at their salary cap situation
they've got it still even with the
carson winch trade they've got a shed
she had some salary cap there to get
under the number and to have enough room
to to
bring in some free agents and help that
offense get better they were good enough
i think on defense that defense played
pretty well they've got to help that
offense get better score more points
this is an offensive game now you've got
to score in the upper 20s low 30s to
contend each and every week and and so
they've got to get better on offense but
here's the other thing mike they play in
the nfc east let's not forget that so
they've got a chance to contend at least
for the division title
next one comes from if i can read this
correctly wisconsin blue crew what's the
cap hit for the colts on this deal can
they restructure the contract 25 for
this year 22 million next year 25 then
26 they can restructure any time they
want if carson wentz is willing to do it
they don't need to do it at 25 4.
they've got a ton of cap space so they
take philip rivers and his 25 out they
put carson wentz and his 25 in dollar
for dollar you know i said this back
when it first looked like the eagles
were going to be trading carson wentz if
you tell
last march
a colts fan that a year from now you're
going to have carson wentz and you're
going to pay him as much as you're
paying phillip rivers they'd have jumped
up and down for joy so i don't think
they need to do anything with the
contract just keep going forward shireen
it's a good deal i mean as quarterback
goes and if he plays really well mike
it's a great deal for the colts
yes absolutely last one from bree guy
fieri do you think that carson wentz
will like whatever indie specialty dish
is more than a cheese steak oh and we
were talking about this during the break
especially steakhouse is everywhere and
it's saying elmo's horseradish sauce for
the shrimp cocktail that clears out your
your entire sinus cavity and burns out
your brain in the process
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports